bouteilles en verre sacs plastiques
cartons ces déchets peuvent mettre
plusieurs centaines d'années à
disparaître dans la nature
armés de gants et de sacs poubelles
c'est 15 randonneurs de la ls elancourt
ont prévu de nettoyer les abords du
sentier sont majoritairement sur le bord
des routes et aux abords des villes est
en fait chaud les chemins sur tout le
sud dès qu'on s'éloigne du ville le
chômage sont relativement propres en
fait les randonneurs sont des gens qui
respectent la nature départ lancé au
mesnil saint denis
à peine quelques mètres et déjà des
trouvailles et plastiques
l'association participe à l'opération
rando net lancé par le comité de la
randonnée pédestre des yvelines un moyen
de sensibiliser le public au respect de
la nature
le trajet se poursuit jusqu'à l'église
de lévis donc le teil du
papier d'alu du plastique hochart papier
c'est principalement ça des petits
morceaux de plastique c'est pas énorme
comme collecte positive du coup oui pour
les chemins sur les chemins le savez que
c'est positif
un maigre butin synonyme de bonnes
nouvelles pour la nature car chaque
année près de 800 millions de tonnes de
déchets sont produits en france